hello everyone
this is gm josh fidel i'll be
doing your uh lecture for tonight i'm
the new jimmy residence for the next few
weeks
and let me mute my own youtube stream i
am watching the comments i'm going to be
doing lots of kind of lecture type stuff
but i will be asking questions so if you
guys are
uh watching on youtube and checking out
the comments i will be
doing that in any case
we're going to start with this game
between
sakis and hebden so this game actually
saki showed this game to me uh in a
training session i have to admit
so but it really left kind of a cool
impression on me because
it was such a cool idea and the way the
game concluded was really nice
um and it sort of does uh it really
illustrates the topic of tonight which
is king power
uh very very well so
uh this is chess bass is what i'm using
so chess bass is the software i use to
to do this uh okay
so this position white obviously has a
dominating position right you have the
queen and f5 bishop on d5 is a monster
the rook on f3 is really strong but the
question is how do you actually convert
this to a full point and it's a lot more
difficult than it looks
uh of course you could play moves like
say c4 and b5
but the problem is that the bishop is
going to land on d4 and that's going to
be kind of annoying and the pawns aren't
really going anywhere right
so it's it's possible to play that way
but i don't think it's actually the
cleanest
so the question is what plan should
white use here
to try to win this game and it's
actually kind of interesting because
the execution of the plan is a little
bit tricky but once you kind of see the
plan
you sort of know what you have to do to
try to win this game
yes king power is how we win well if you
uh
if you're to go by the title of the
lecture it'll really help you out a lot
so so trade queens that get king up is a
nice idea
so tr but the problem with this is that
your king takes a while to get to the
center of the board so by that time it's
possible black will have set up
something kind of nice and also you need
a clear way to trade queens right
uh because at the moment it's not so
easy actually how you trade queens
um so i mean you have moves like bishop
c6 you could try but i don't know that
it's actually that clear
um that you're gonna be able to trade
queens that easily number one and number
two that it'll actually be that easy to
win
uh a position even if you do trade the
queens
so what other ideas could white possibly
have in this position
and once again guys i am watching
youtube chat for some things so if you
guys
uh have some ideas don't be afraid to
shout them out
i usually don't yell at people for bad
ideas and bad ideas are kind of part of
the deal so it's not a bit not so
so big so we can push our pawns as i
said pushing the c
and b pawns is nice but you're not
really doing that much you can push the
pawn to g4 but again it doesn't seem to
accomplish too much
it's a weird position because black
doesn't have that many moves
but it's also tough for white to improve
their own position
uh yeah good event so that's the right
idea you want to play with king f1 and
king f1
is a perfectly good move here uh in the
game he played king g2 first
because he wanted to do something with
tempe and you'll kind of see what i mean
with that
but quite honestly both moves are
perfectly fine and should do the job
so he starts with king g2 which is kind
of an amusing move so black doesn't
really have much to do right
they can't really move the queen
anywhere because anywhere they move the
queen
they're gonna get hit with something so
the queen has to cover f6 right if you
try to go to c7 for instance and i play
queen f6
check you're going to have a very very
long day and by long day i mean you're
probably just going to resign in a move
or two because you have to hold on to h6
and f7 and it's just impossible
if you try to play queen d8 guarding the
f6 square i can take this pawn very
safely and even though i'm pinned up
queen g6 is a threat that's also game
over
uh the rook can't move because you
simply take the pawn on f7 with queen
and that's going to be completely
winning so really all and the king can't
move either the king tries to move back
for example you have the very evil queen
g6 check
and that will also be all she wrote with
queen
takes and the idea is that the pawn is
pinned so you're not able to take the
queen
so that being said even though there are
no real threats for white the king can't
really move so the bishop is the only
piece that can move and it can only move
to one square really
it can go to b8 as well but that's very
ugly and
certainly not an improvement right so
black tries to just play bishop b6
and now the king moves over so once
again black just has no moves they play
bishop back
bishop back king d3 bishop here so we've
achieved our
goal of king to d3 uh if we ever trade
queens or something like this this is
definitely a massive improvement but the
question is how do we further our
position from here
that's sort of the tricky part like how
do we improve our position from
now that we have the king on d3 the
question is do we bring the king further
or do we try something else
that's a nice idea chess king but where
how are you recruiting them right like
what are you doing with them
that's possible but think about this
right you put your king on d3 if you
start playing moves like queen h3 rook
f5
all of a sudden black's gonna probably
play you know queen c7 rook c8 at some
point
uh maybe after playing f6 and then it's
not going to be so easy right because
all of a sudden so let's say queen h3
for example right
i'm not exactly sure what move black
would try here but let's say
for instance maybe queen c7 right
so if queen goes back to f5 i go back to
e7 no big deal if you try rook f5 maybe
i even play f6 and the whole point is
that now i'm ready to play rook c8
and you're kind of playing without your
rook here right
maybe this is still like a playable
option for you like
i'm not saying this is terrible maybe
forcing f6 is worthwhile
but it feels a little weird to move your
queen and rook back like this
playing for f4 is also very interesting
but it also takes a lot of moves and
keep in mind
your own king on d3 might become exposed
if you try to do that
so white had another idea entirely
bringing the key to a6 is actually quite
interesting and in fact in this position
white did play king c4
so it looks a little bit crazy but the
idea is that you still want to bring the
king over
uh to the queen side right and this is a
reasonable way to do it
um so here if black were to play
bishop b6 you could kind of continue
with the planet in the game so we won't
go over that just yet
but in the game black played king queen
c7 check so now where do you go with
your king do you play the brave king b5
or
the slightly more sensible king b3
yeah king b3 is a little bit more
sensible keem b5 is possible
i'm not saying it's impossible but it
doesn't really achieve that much because
i can always force you back if i want to
and the king there is a little bit a
little bit hairy at the moment right
yeah i mean maybe you can get away with
it right um
and it might also be okay but i would
say that it's not really necessary right
and and
so white simply just goes back to b3
yeah
um again i don't think you get mated if
you play king b5 as you pointed out
if rook check king here you've actually
done uh white a favor because now the
queen of six and queen of seven are both
kind of in the air uh and if you try
queen b6 check king a4
i'm guessing the queen's also a bit
misplaced you have check and the problem
is you're threatening queen of six check
and you just kind of
i don't know though i would be nervous
about this right because now you have to
calculate moves
like say queen back to a1 trying to
harass the king
if queen f6 king h7 bishop f7 you have
to hope that you don't get mated or
something
probably this is good enough you know
maybe you have something but i don't
think it's necessary right
just play king b3 you you don't want to
go too crazy especially when you have
such a winning position
because now black has to just go back
right there's nothing to do otherwise
queen f6 check is coming
so they have to go to e7 and now this is
kind of the crucial moment
because here white actually has a way to
put black in a sort of
and this is very very nice
bishop c6 is quite an interesting move
it's probably okay
the drawback of bishop c6 is that you
don't you kind of
you enable so let's say you play bishop
c6 here the problem here is that you
enable the rook and the queen to kind of
move now the queen maybe doesn't want to
move because the pawn
the square of f6 but maybe the rook can
move so say something like
rook b8 is maybe a possibility now
and again maybe you can just play queen
d7 and the endgame is good enough
a position like this you have many ways
to actually win right
but yes this is white to play
yeah so remember c4 is kind of going to
give you the same issues that it had
before it allows the bishop to d4 and
then maybe black can use the a file
i would be a little bit careful with
that
so in all these end games so bishop c6
is a great idea it's actually similar to
what was played in the game
but in all these end games you have to
make sure your opponents really lock
down
um and that your pieces are optimally
positioned they're all in their best
possible squares
so one of the ways you can do this is by
finding a way to further improve your
pieces
and then only then trying to trade
queens
so what he chose in the game was the
move g4 and this is really sweet
um because at first it looks weird just
putting your pawns on the same color as
your bishop but the fact is that
you're now preventing any counter play
black could get in the end game with the
move g4
uh himself so if black were to try this
in the end game may be annoying now
you're completely shutting it out
and you're making it so the black
doesn't really have any moves so of
course they bring the bishop back to b6
and now the king comes up to c4 and the
whole idea is that if queen c7 check now
you can play king b5
and notice how there's no key there's no
queen b6 check because this bishop is on
a very unfortunate square on b6 now
so because of that queen of six check is
a threat and black's actually just
toast here like black can already resign
so in the game black tried bishop a7
king to c6 is maybe a bit much i mean
you're going to ask for queen e8 each
and stuff like that
but the king is definitely on its way
forward and that's indeed what was
played here
so king to b5 was played and
it's really a cool idea because think
about it like the only difference
between this and the starting position
apart from the pawn on g4 is the fact
that the king's on b5 now
but the fact is that king on b5 is kind
of scary and black now takes steps to
try to
parry it so for example if rook be a
check here
and i guess i'll ask you guys one more
question do you get brave with a move
like king a6 or do you try to retreat
so your choices are king to a6 or trying
to retreat with
or trying to retreat with the king you
could also try king c6
i'm not gonna lie this is a move but
after rook b6 mate you might rethink
this
king a6 yes
yeah and this move is actually winning
because if you play rook
b6 check i simply play back with king a5
and you don't really have any great
checks now
and quite xf7 is on the horizon and
probably going to
crush black next move so black could try
something like rook f8
but now you simply take on f7 and after
all the the trades
taking on f7 by the way is not the only
way to win i should point this out
this is not the only way to do things
however after a position like this
you can simply drop back to the bishop
and even though the f2 pawn is gone look
at this king on a6 it's a beauty right
and you're just gonna run this pawn up
until you get a queen basically
and this position should be quite easy
to uh to win
so just as an example right of how this
can go wrong
so queen eh check was tried in the game
which is definitely the best try
and then once again here you have to
find the right way to play because here
trying to come up with
king a6 allowing queen check here is not
really something you want to do
this is an example of a king that's a
bit too brave so for example now you can
play rook b8 check
bishop b6 check and you win the rook but
you end up getting checkmated so trying
to win this way i would say is not the
best course of action
but white does have another really good
move here
well i do like it yeah i mean and this
is uh
kind of one of the ideas that one that
you guys have thought about already
which is this bishop c6 move because now
you're ready to bring your queen to d7
where it's going to be really really
nice
um so here
there are all sorts of ideas so if in
the game black played queen d8 if queen
e7 you can play queen d7
so black tried this which is maybe a
better try
uh because here you're threatening queen
b6 check and queen b6 check is quite a
powerful threat right
because with queen b6 you're going to
take the bishop with check
so white retreats and now black tries
queen e7 if they play queen b6 you have
a few options but i think the cleanest
is simply queen f6 check
and taking the d6 pawn and this should
get the job done the king is actually
quite safe there because
if queen a6 check you can simply play
pmb3 nothing really horrible is
happening
and this is actually just a completely
winning position
uh there are so many possible threats
here that i think black black's gonna
struggle to
to make it a few more moves like moves
like rick has six are in the air and
this king is actually not so bad on c4
uh yeah quite an example so in the game
queen e7 was tried
but now white goes for the queen trade
and the whole idea is that once you
trade queens
the fact that your king is so much
better than your opponents plays a big
role
so this king f1 e2 d3 c4
sure you could have tried to trade
queens first but then black can also
improve their own king
here you've improved your king kind of
for free
and improving your king for free in an
end game is very powerful
so black tried to move queen e6 which is
interesting qui takes d7
is maybe i don't want to say objectively
best because everything loses right but
uh it's easy to see why black didn't
want this right because you do something
like this
and here you can just play bishop back
to c6 and king up to d5
and because your king is so powerful
you're threatening to take on d6 your
pawns are coming up the board
i think that this position would be
quite an easy win uh for white
so in the game he tried queen e6 check
and even though all the rooks get traded
and you get to an opposite bishop end
game because the white king is so
powerful here
it was it's a fairly simple win
uh so he played king b5 in the game you
could even be very sadistic and careful
and play the move f3
and basically say ah you got nothing and
after king e7
the key point is that in this position
you have a very very important move
which also can come into play during the
game
any guesses what that move might be
now don't get me wrong i actually like
the way he did it in the game better in
some ways because i feel like
he uh he was playing kind of he was kind
of pushing his advantages
but technically this is also completely
winning
so chess king it's actually very
important which one you play if you play
the move c4 and i play king c7
it's not actually so easy now because
black's king on c7 is quite good
uh that that king is actually going to
be quite an annoyance for you
um and make your life kind of difficult
right because it controls the b6 square
so king b7 is actually the killer move
and this is actually just completely
winning so even if black
grabs the c pawn which is absolutely
something they can do
there's not really anything they can do
here because this king on
on v8 and you'll see that the eight
you'll see this pattern in the game as
well
is so completely shut out of the game
that they're basically just waiting to
waiting to get slaughtered here um
and you still have to be careful for
example after a move like this
uh you still have to be cautious but i
think you just move your bishop back for
example
and this pawn on b6 is just going to end
up becoming a queen or becoming
way too strong so sure black can play a
move like this
but even this kind of move is not going
to really help too much you can probably
maybe just bishop even back to c6 is
fine
um or even bishop to b3 right just
be ready to take this pawn and if they
take you take back
and again it's just a position where
they really can't do much
and because of that you're you're going
to win this
fairly simply because you're just going
to be able to push your pawn up and your
king's just going to be able to have
free reign here you're going to play
king to c6 at some point
and then just play b7 and mop up all the
pawns
i don't know if this was actually the
most precise way bishop b3 to do it
maybe king here is actually a bit nicer
i don't know
because now you're threatening b7 and to
take um
so maybe this is a bit better than what
i played you prevent king d7 ideas and
all of this
the main problem is that black has just
too many pawn weaknesses and
there's no way to guard all of them so
at some point you're gonna lose
something
but again you have many ways you can try
to do it but this would also win
king b5 was played in the game so he
basically just gambits this pawn
but this is also quite a clear way to do
it because now he plays c4
and then puts the king on b7 and this is
a very very clear
uh path to victory so the idea is bishop
b1
b5 bishop back b6 so it's very similar
to our previous example
he just has a c4 pawn instead of an f3
pawn
but it's actually very very similar so
bishop d4
and now he simply clears the c6 square
for his king
and here black has a lot of different
options but they all kind of lead to
zug's wong in some fashion so for
example bishop e3 king c6
now if bishop c5 you play b7 and the
whole point is that the bishop has to
now cover the pawn and you can just
start munching so you take this pawn
you'll take these pawns you'll rock over
and take h6
it's just too much and if you play
bishop c5
it's actually a cute position because
you can play here and black just has no
good moves the king can't really move
away because of king c7
if the bishop moves in either direction
you're going to have a problem if it
moves
this way you can actually play king a8
and now this pawn is just going to
become a queen or win a bishop or
something
and if you go this direction now i go
here and now your b
d pawn is hanging um so it's a big
problem
in the game he played d5 and he was able
to win pretty simply
he simply gets another pass pawn moves
his pawns up
guards against the e pawn checks and
plays kinky seven in black resigned
uh probably in a position like this the
best try is a move like e2
um but after bishop takes e2 king b7
you have many ways to win in my opinion
the simplest is doing this
putting the pawn on d7 forcing this and
now black has no moves right they have
to just basically do this all day
so you put the bishop on its beautiful
f5 square
they come back you play king f7 they
have to come back if they try to go this
way you play here
threatening queens and then here and
that's unstoppable
so they must play bishop back to d8
and now you simply walk over and take
the pawns
with a very easy one so that was that
game
very very nice example of how to play
properly with your king in the end game
really really sweet game and definitely
one i really enjoy
so moving on
and here was another game
okay so let's make sure we have
everything correct
okay so i should change the
ah one moment
okay
so now we have the game salvo rosa fidel
so i was playing black here
uh again in a tournament in germany in
2007.
my opponent was bernard uh salvon roser
and i was this was an opponent it was
actually a really funny situation it was
it ended up being one of the last games
in the tournament all and this guy
impressed me so much
not just with how he played but he
impressed me with
like the ferocity with which he played
like he wanted to win this game so badly
um and the way he played was just really
really sweet in this endgame from the
white side
um so you know and he was rated 200
points below me i was like a
high rated im at the time and he was
like i think 2280 i was about 24
80. so it was a pretty big gap between
us and he was the one who was pushing
and trying for a win and in general i
was just very impressed
and in my mind when i think about king
power in an end game this is the game i
think about
from my own career um and it was just a
really really interesting game as well
so let's get started it's a pretty it
looks like it's a very simple position
first of all
and during the game i did i thought that
okay knight on c4
connected past pawns this should just be
a draw right like there's no way the
rook can defeat those pawns if the king
tries to run up
then my pawns start rolling and in
general i was just
not i just thought we were gonna shake
hands and then the game would be over
i really thought that that's how this
game would end
but i turns out i could not have been
farther from the truth
uh and this game again went to be the
last game done in the tournament hall
that round
uh i recall so he played the move king
a4
so fair enough my plan here is basically
just to sit so
i play king d8 and my plan is to
basically sit and go between
these two squares king e8 king d8 till
the end of time
and basically claim if you ever try to
move your king up
for example with king b5 now i play b3
and if king c6 i play b2 and now you're
probably in huge trouble
because my a pawn is going to run up the
board as well and your king can't go to
d6 because my beautiful c4 knight
so i could tell he really wanted to win
but i actually thought he was gonna get
into trouble by trying to win
um but instead he actually played this
in a remarkable way so
he played rook h7 instead fair enough so
i play king eight of course it's a
mistake to play king
c8 because then you allow rookie seven
and he can capture my ipon
so kiki it's really the only try but
then here he came up with a very clever
idea
in order to improve his king this game
is all about king power
and the king is the piece that's most
impressive in this whole game
so what do you think white could try to
activate their king here
and that's the thing chess king i really
thought that it would be just so
difficult for white to activate their
king that's why i thought we were just
gonna shake hands around here
and i think against a lot of opponents i
would uh what's funny is my judgment of
the position was correct but i
underestimated severely how complicated
this position is
so this is b5 by the way uh not sure if
you can see the coordinates but i'm
playing black here so white could play
king b5
but this move would again be a mistake
because i can simply push my pawn
and even though the king is becoming
active my pawn has become a one or right
freight train
and after for example a move like rook
b7 i simply keep pushing my a pawn
and white's only going to be able to
lose this they're not going to be able
to win
so the problem with rook b7 chess king
is that king c6
king b5 is still not a possible move
because of b3
so how can he actually be able to play
king b5
he needs to be able to play king b5 you
guys are right on the money about that
but how can he actually achieve his aim
you
very good chess king that's exactly the
correct idea
so you're correct brian that it's rook
h3
because now it looks like a weird
passive move but you're preventing the
pawn from advancing by
putting the rook on h3 and now your
king's ready to come up so i played king
d7 king f7 is possible here
but it doesn't really help me yes my
king's starting to come up but if white
simply slides the rook over with a move
like this
my king is now stuck on f7 and can't
actually move
so this wouldn't actually help me so i
played the d7
but now king b5 so now he's coming up
right
so i play king c7 there's not much else
for me to do here
he plays king c5 very important move by
the way
rook h7 check
and here again i'm kind of stuck because
my pawns can't really move so easily and
his king is ready to come up if i try
king c8 here for example
he can simply bring his king to c6 and
he's threatening mate so this is
problematic so i played king d8 so i
totally missed that he could do this
idea
he plays rook b7 so here it's clear to
me that
i missed this but i still thought i
should be okay the knight on c4 is still
gorgeous he still has to worry about the
b-pawn
so i play king c8 my idea now is if he
tries to play rookie 7 b3
he's way too slow this b-pawn actually
queens on him if he tries to take right
i go here
pawn push he can play this clever move
threatening mate but the problem is once
i defend against the maid he actually
just resigns because the b pawn is way
too strong
it's just going to make a new queen um
and if he tries to play rook b5 sorry
now king c7 and he's actually in
zugzwang he has no moves here
which is quite an embarrassing situation
i must say but yeah this would be quite
bad for him of course so he plays king
c6 which is his only move
but it's a good one because notice how
neither of my pawns can move because the
rook's now behind them
except now his king's on c6 instead of
a4
so he's definitely making progress and
to say i was a little bit worried
is an understatement i was quite a bit
worried here because
i didn't see you could get this but at
the same time i still wasn't panicking
i'm like okay
his pieces are still there they're
decent whatever but he still can't
actually penetrate can he the net on c4
controls the d6 square
so he plays rook pa check king e7 rook
b5
so we repeat moves a couple times and he
plays this
so okay i play king e8 he checks
comes back we go here and he plays rook
b7 so i thought it's now the time he's
finally gonna
let me draw but the answer is no he
plays king c7
and rook b8 and here i'm thinking wait a
second he can actually do this
i forget if i offered a draw i probably
didn't because it was clear he was
intent on winning
but i was like wow he's really gonna try
to do this okay
so he plays king c7 so i thought that
this potential
was potentially was coming but i thought
that this would be way too risky from
white's side
because now there's no going back now
like he had that draw
but now there's absolutely no going back
um because here i have an idea where i'm
trying the one actually trying to push
for a win now
uh once i try this idea now keep in mind
like white can still try to win but what
i'm saying is that it's not just an easy
draw anymore once he plays this
it's a double-edged position so it's
kind of like point of no return
so what is my idea here to be able to
get counterplay for the king and rook
trying to box me out here
yeah it was it was far earlier in the
game i want to say it was the end game i
don't even remember the beginning part
of the game honestly i
mainly remember this end game
yeah exactly it's morteza so knight d2
is what i played
with the idea that after king c6 i play
b3
and i'm gonna play a4 and a3 so this is
what i mean by point of no return
he now does not have a simple draw
he has to be very very careful that my
pawns don't queen on him
but he calculated a while and we didn't
have time unlimited time in this game it
was nearing the end
but he had a bit of time and he
calculated this out
so rook b7 check was played and here i
took a very long think
because i realized that correctly
it was a very important decision
unfortunately for myself of the three
squares that i can go to f8
e8 and d8
i actually chose the worst one
so despite the fact that i gave it all
this time i still didn't figure it out
properly
but let's see if you guys can do better
which of the three moves
would be your choice and keep in mind
that it's not that there's necessarily a
like clearly best answer there's
actually only a clearly worst answer
so the question is what would you guys
do
f8 says brian okay
this is by the way a very difficult
decision so you guys probably can't
figure it out in a few minutes again i
took i'm sure i took like 10 minutes
here
because it was a very important decision
um
so f8 you guys want fa dave wants f8
okay
so we have two f8s any other votes
anything else
we have an e8 okay fair enough
so yeah you guys are correct that e8 and
d8 are the best girls i actually went to
f8 which a couple of you wanted
with the idea that i didn't want my king
anywhere near the opposing king because
i didn't want to have them threatened
made
but the fact was that gives my opponent
some very very good opportunities that
they wouldn't normally have
so if king e8 you can actually draw
uh so if k rook b a check first of all
king f7 i'm actually winning
because my king is escaping and my pawns
are running so he has to try king d6
and here the key is that i have this
move b2 and i think i must have missed
this
which is very clever because if king
takes e6 of course
which is what he should do threatening
mate i play b1 queen preventing me
and here we just actually trade to this
end game and even though i'm up a piece
it's a very dead draw because his king
simply runs over to
to deal with the pawn so i don't know
exactly what i would do here but let's
say for example
i don't know knight d2 king here there's
just no way for me to guard my pawn
safely i can't get my king knight behind
the pawn
the two connectors would make that
probably drush anyway
so probably i would just do something
like this
and then come here and when we draw
right
pretty easy draw so king e8 would secure
a draw because of that nice little
tactic but if you don't see the b2
tactic
that doesn't really ever work king d8
is also very good and i think what i
missed here was after king d6 i can
actually play king c8 and it's not so
easy here
for the main reason that if rook b5
again i have this b2 tactic
uh which saves the day and if rook c7
check kb8 he actually just loses because
b2 is coming probably
and if he has to play king c6 i can
simply push my pawn because he's no
longer making too many threats
i was a little worried to move my king
back in that corner and i think that it
was more of a
kind of a visual decision than a
calculated well calculated decision
but a position like this the main lesson
is you have to be calculating extremely
well and i
wasn't really up to the task in this
game uh because
i think if i calculated e8 or da
thoroughly i would have played there
but i play king f8 and again during a
game there's more pressure you don't
know
exactly what's at stake in your decision
it's a little bit more difficult but at
the same time
i think this is a good lesson and when
you just have to calculate
very precisely and not rely so much on
intuition as far as where your king goes
because intuition can definitely lie to
you
so i played king f8 he played king d7
and this is the problem i've given him
the d7 square
for his king so he doesn't have to step
on d6 and d6 is almost
like a mine square because of this b2
idea right because of the knight fork
so because of it he doesn't have to step
on the mine square i actually have an
issue now
and i think i just totally missed that
king d7 was a thing
so if king f7 he simply plays king d6
and now it's with check so he actually
just wins because he just captures my
pawn
and he's gonna be too fast so i play a4
what else can i do
king takes e6 a3 again my hand's kind of
forced i have to go for
queening upon because i just don't have
anything else he plays king d7 and here
i realized that
man these tactics are not going to work
out for me so well
this king is just so strong and then a2
and e6 and then this position
is literally one of the most complicated
positions probably that i've played
but um certainly that i've played at
least you know obviously there have been
more complicated positions in history
i'm sure i've played some more
but especially considering the limited
material the complexity of this position
is quite something
uh so in this position and to give you
an idea this position is so complicated
even when you turn on stockfish it
doesn't figure it out right away
it takes a long time to actually figure
it out maybe with someone with a better
machine than i
but here's the question actually
do you play queens with a1 queen or do
you play b2 with the idea of queening
next move
uh and that is kind of the question on
the table here
and i remember also giving this question
quite a bit of thought
but it is quite a difficult one so take
your time and what are the possibilities
with b2 and with a1 queen which one
would you guys prefer
so complicated decision so take your
time i would definitely not
rush it because again it's so
complicated right like
that computers have trouble figuring it
out is
telling enough but i would say that at
the very least you
you can figure out which move is better
and that's kind of the more important
you don't have to figure out which move
ends in a draw or which move doesn't or
whatever else
because that's really difficult but you
can at least figure out which move is
better
and that's kind of the key
that's kind of what i thought subhankar
actually but it turns out
yeah 94 is the other possibility but
knight e4 will make you very sad and
i'll show you why in a moment
so i guess let's get out of that out of
the way if knight e4 which looks very
clever at first because after e7
king g7 it looks like you're gonna play
knight f6 and actually just win the game
the problem is after queens knight f6
check white plays king e6 and
unfortunately that is also a check
so knight f6 actually just loses because
this wins immediately
so 94 looks very clever but in fact it
actually just loses
so yeah chess king you actually hit one
of the main lines so the best move here
is
definitely b2 um
i could play king g7 by the way and this
transposes because after e7 i have to
play b2 anyway so it doesn't really
matter
uh which one you play first i don't
believe but it's the same thing you play
b2
so here if rook takes b2 you simply get
a queen and this position is going to be
quite decent for black because after
here
your brook's attacked right so you have
to queen and then i take the rook and
okay white can take the d-pawn and draw
but they're not going to win this
position
so e7 check is best
queen and then black queens
so here we've reached the start and as
chess king points out
they absolutely found the best idea if
you try to play king c6 check
now i simply take the rook and queen and
once again i'm very happy even though
it's a draw
so rook c7 is the really testing move
and this position is the one that's
immensely complicated
because because white's moving the king
with check it's just so
frightening so you have to find the
correct move here
and i have to say that i think that i
don't even think i saw this
during the game i mean we neither of us
had tons of time at this point and i
definitely didn't see all of this
um but i definitely was very worried
about queening a move later
even though the key is that the queen
hit the brook on b7 right that was the
key
so because of that i didn't lose a tempo
by queening the b-pawn
because remember the b-pawns one moves
slower than queen in the a-pawn
but the key is that the queen on b1 and
pawn on a2 give me more options here
because the queen on a1 is actually more
out of play than the queen on b1
the question is though what do i
actually play here right
because it's not actually that simple
also since we're talking king power look
at this king on d7 what a monster that
guys right
look what it did to me this game i was
basically traumatized only by this king
the problem is though rahul that how do
you actually do it because remember
the king's going to move with check so
if you play queen b5 thinking you're
going to trade queens
think again because you're actually just
going to get mated or lose your queen at
the very least right
so that would not be very good
so king f6 i think you get mated with
king f6 so something like rook c6
check i want to say or no sorry queen e5
check is very strong because it
pings your king down right so now if you
play king f7 i move my king with check
and if you go here i play check and now
you're gonna get mated for sure
you're just not gonna have enough right
yeah so guys just to point this out
because i saw this a few times queen b5
check is met with king e6
check remember
and here you actually just lose so you
have to be very very careful you can't
just check the king for no reason right
like the the king moves with check not
for no reason of course
um so king f6 doesn't work because of
queen e5 check
you could try king h6 i think was a
better try
uh but here i can play rookie six check
i believe and then after here queen e3
check and this is mate
it's not made immediately but it's made
after several moves because the problem
is i can't stop the rook from getting
into the attack
and once the queen and rook work
together my king's just too naked it's
just it has no help of defense
so the line would go something like this
check
so the idea is that if knight f3 i can
play queen g2 and
win the knight this way and or be able
to check with the rook at the very least
like everything's will check so king f5
queen check
king e4 queen check and the key is that
now
my rook gets in the game and he can't
stop it
so once this happens and again there are
many many variations but the basic gist
is that once and again this seems
unnecessary right
and then here there's one final blow you
guys can find
but once the rook gets into the game
even with my monster knight on d2
there is a way to win the game
yeah and again guys don't worry about
suggesting moves that
may not be may not work if you miss
something i mean we all miss things
right so but suggesting is kind of how
you learn about it
um so i'm never gonna judge you too
harshly for your movie i mean
that's actually not completely true just
kidding
but uh you know it's not really about
whether your move is good or not it's
like
kind of getting things out there and
learning things but yeah you got it roxy
one check is very strong
so the idea is you have to take it
legally and then queen check and i take
your queen
and this should be winning so king h6
doesn't work
making a queen in this position trying
to get two queens is too greedy this
doesn't work either i play
for example king d8 check and then the
key is once again this queen check
and i just have to make sure your queens
can't block right
and once i get my rook into the game
like this
i'm able to take and here because the
king is just totally naked and the
queens are not helping enough
uh white will be able to give checkmate
here
so again i mean like the reason i'm not
showing all the lines is
simply because there's too many um so if
in these lines you're thinking oh what
about this what about this trust me it's
all there
but um this is most certainly
the very best so instead though i played
queen
thinking that well queening a move
sooner has to at least be okay
but the fact is that actually queening a
tempo later which normally would be
horrible right you're getting a queen to
move later think about how extreme that
is
because you hit the rook is actually
good
but this position i realized as soon as
i got here i was in big trouble because
checking the king the king moves with
check
so the best move i i found was simply
taking this pawn
and this move loses by force but at the
same time there's not much else to do i
could try queen a6
but at the very least white can just
take this pawn and this is just dead
um i have no checks and the queen's very
strong and it's just losing
so i tried taking and here my opponent
played king e6 check but believe it or
not he has an even more crushing way to
win
uh and it's really beautiful just
because of the concept of how this move
works
so king e6 check is what he played which
is good enough to win
uh with best play but he actually has
a very very clean way to do this which
is really really neat so try to find it
it's a little bit tricky but
it's uh it's actually a really sweet way
to win
so john the the pawns are i'm black here
right
so the pawns are moving up the board not
the other way
and yes it's very easy to lose track of
where the pawns are going in a position
like this
it's very uh easy to do so don't worry
about it too much but yeah the pawns are
going
up the board um right this is b3 this is
d5
but yeah don't worry about that that
happens to everyone that's a very common
thing
yeah queen e7 check maybe win also i'm
not sure uh it's very likely
uh but it's kind of a similar thing like
the king
my king's going to try to move up the
board
yeah like this this is probably good
enough to win something like queen e7
check
it's probably similar to what he did
honestly where
my king moves up the board right so
check and probably i just
try to run right uh the advantage though
is that if my king ever gets here
which is very funny because eventually
in the game this is kind of what
happened
he has to be careful probably here it's
still winning i would guess
but again he has many ways to win here
the coolest though
which is very tricky is actually playing
queen h5 queen e6 is a very good guess
by the way but not quite as strong as
this move
and this move is just all kinds of nasty
because he's threatening kingy sex check
right
but i have like no way to stop this move
if i try to play king f6 he simply
skewers me with queen hha check and wins
the queen
probably has other wins too but that's
the simplest and otherwise i just can't
stop this check because i can't even
attack his rook that's the key this rook
can't be attacked on b7
so if i could attack that rook i'd have
a better shot but i can't even do that
so i basically just have to wait for
king e6 check and if queen f6
he can play king e8 check and now i just
lose because after king here this is me
so a real brutal finish to the game
would have been queen h5 that's a really
sweet move
and honestly he would have deserved it
like he deserved to win this game i
definitely did not
but moving to that he played king e6
check which is still good enough i
should point this out
i play king h6 because i have to run
right there's no other choice but
running
and he plays the move queen f6 f8 check
which is good
and here i thought i was going to resign
in a few moves quite honestly
but luckily he was very low on time
probably we were both low but he
was quite a bit lower so if i play king
g5 he simply plays rook g7 check
and forces me to sack my queen so i play
king h5
but the question is how does white win
here
because this was the moment where he
actually threw away the win
um it was with this move
and again i was expecting to just shake
his hand in a couple moves and be like
too good man
i would have been a little upset right
but it's like he outplayed me what am i
gonna do
i don't know everyone has their own
games that make them upset right in this
case though it was like just getting
outplayed
obviously you can hope to play better
but
so guys it's very important to play
moves with tempo right because
he can't just get away with playing rook
g7 and saying well you can't stop queen
h8 because here i can play queen b6
check there's queen e4 check
i'm going to start checking him a bunch
and that's not going to be that clear
because it's really hard to get out of
checks in an open board like this
the reason why he i couldn't get out of
checks before rather he couldn't get out
of checks before
or could sorry is that he could move his
king with check right here he can't
so the better version is rook h7 check
because now he i have to play something
like king g4 if i try king g6 i actually
get mated in one with this move that is
checkmate
so king g4 and now he simply slides over
so the queen is going to slide to h8
with mate
right if the king tries to move back
this is going to be mate
and if i try to go up the board like say
this
he has many ways to win again but queen
of five checks the simplest then he's
gonna give mayton a couple moves
because my king's gonna be stuck on the
edge of the board um
and he can play for example queen h7
check next and it's gonna be over
um and after i sack my queen
he simply can play here and take the
pawn and his queen's too good and
i would just be losing um
so in the game however he played queen
f5 check
which looks at first like it's plenty
good enough
but again he was short on time he wasn't
sure and the problem here
and i think this is what he missed is
that in this position
if he tries to check my king up the
board like this i simply play king here
and he actually has no more checks that
are good
so he actually has to be careful here
so you'd think he'd be winning here
right chess king but he actually is not
winning at all
so here he played queen h3 check because
he wasn't sure what else he was again
playing on seconds king f2
i think i was as well at this point rook
f7 check
king e2 so end of the game check king
here and then this was the crucial
moment
because here obviously things have gone
horribly horribly astray
but he's not lost yet he still has a
chance to save the game after queen
takes d5 it's just a draw
i could try to push my pawn but he
simply goes here and sacks with the rook
right
because if we trade queens i play b1 he
simply takes with this rook and it's
just knight against king right
but instead he again panicked a little
bit and this is where keeping your comm
under pressure really helps
uh he played the move queen of five
check and here i think he just blundered
i think he was still trying to win which
is probably just unwise at this point
but sometimes you kind of lose sight of
your goal when you're just playing off
of seconds right
and it's really important to kind of
keep calm and here this move actually
loses um i'm sure you guys can figure
out what
what move is very good against queen f5
check
very good queen e4 and it's a check
so he doesn't have time to take on d5 or
do anything else again it was last
minute he grabbed the queen i took with
the pawn and he just
i think he lost on time but he's lost
here because b2 is coming and e pawn is
coming
and he just can't hold his own against
all these pawns so for example if rook
b7
i could play just e3 and the game is
going to be over uh very very soon
so in this position he i forget whether
he resigned i think he lost on time but
he it's a resignable position in any
case
so kind of a crazy end to the whole game
uh to be perfectly honest like not
not exactly the way i expected it and
again he really outplayed me almost all
of this end game like he played very
impressively the earlier part of the
game i remember was kind of weird and
probably i should have done better than
i did but and then in this end game he
played so impressively and it was only
because of time and because he may be
pushed too hard at the end that the win
turned into a draw then turned into a
loss
uh but this is kind of what happened but
i do want you to notice one thing
in the end who's the hero of this
position
it's the black king on t3 so and the
only reason why this was possible is
because my king went on a walkabout
so the king can be such an important
piece in all of these end games um
and it's not something to be
underestimated so think about always can
i improve my king whether it's making it
safer or whether it's going on a bit of
a walk
braving some danger but the rewards as
you can see can be quite great
in any case i hope you i hope you
uh enjoyed these examples and i will be
back on thursday
for the gm choice and for uh
games of the week so i hope you enjoy
that and i will see you then